Shut up, S!
♪♪
♪ Hello ♪
What, dude?
[ Laughs ]
[ Gasps ]
Alan mother[bleep] Cumming.
Oh, my God.
Who is that?
Both: Alan Cumming!
Saul!
Alan Cumming --
the magical, pansexual,
New York City
party boi-nymph
in the beautiful flesh!
I have chills.
Okay, should we
follow him?
I mean,
I think we have to.
What?
I'm starving!
Okay, it is not about you
right now, honey.
Saul, we're talking
about Alan Cumming
from -- from
"Romy and Michelle,"
from "The Anniversary Party,"
from "The Good Wife,"
from "Spice World" fame,
Saul.
I mean, Alan Cumming
created his own perfume line
called "Cumming."
[ Laughs ]
Is that LOL genie
or what?
I'm wearing it
right now.
Saul, I swear
to Adonai,
whatever Alan Cumming has
in store for today,
you will be
titillated by it.
Yes.
He represents the real
New York, okay?
The -- The pre-9/11,
pre-"Sex in the City,"
Basquiat,
Keith Haring New York.
The only Haring I'm interested
in is pickled herring.
And as soon as we can
get to that, I am fine.
Okay. We'll do it.
You got yourself a deal.
Got yourself a deal.
Let's go, let's go. Let's go.
We'll make it happen.
All right!
Come on, Saul.
We gotta catch up with him.
Hurry it up.
♪♪
-Alright.
-Alright. We're gonna catch up.
Giddy-up, Saul!
Come on!
We got it, Saul.
Shit, shit!
Here we go.
We're losing him.
Okay. Alright.
We got --
[ Gasps ]
Drag brunch!
We must!
We must?
[ Groans ]
Okay.
-Come on, brother!
-Here we go.
♪ You're our guest ♪
♪ Jiggly Caliente is the best ♪
♪ Tuck your dick
between your legs ♪
♪ And shake those unfeasibly
large breasts ♪
♪ A generous pour,
contours and curves ♪
♪ All the drinks
that you deserve ♪
♪ We are dressed
in all couture ♪
♪ Just ask our queen,
Sasha Velour ♪
♪ Undo your belt,
loosen your pants ♪
♪ Tip your waitress,
she's freelance ♪
♪ Our mimosa pours will
always past the test ♪
♪ Come on
and bring your nephew ♪
♪ Apply your blush
and then you'll pass the test ♪
♪ Touch my chest ♪
♪ You're our guest ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
Can I take your order,
baby?
Yes. Can I get a coffee
with a side of you?
-Wooo!
-Oh!
Sau-ul.
Looks like I got a fresh one,
mm-hmm?
I love this place.
Thank you.
And I love money,
so make sure y'all tip, okay?
-Yes.
-I'll be back, doll.
Okay.
Love it.
♪♪
[ Sighing ] Oof!
That was good.
Oh, my God, Ilana.
He's at the bar.
♪♪
We have to go pay
our respects.
Okay.
Let's vape
and loosen up a little bit.
Okay. Thanks.
♪♪
Oh, Saul,
this is a marijuana pen.
Ooh, sorry.
You probably don't want that.
Why shouldn't I
get high?
[ Piano music plays lightly ]
Yeah, go for it.
Get ripped, 'cuz.
[ Coughs ]
You can't get off
unless you cough!
That's for damn sure.
[ Both laugh ]
Both: Conga time!
Ooh, come on, girls.
Oh, my gosh, Abbi,
his friend just left him,
leaving him all alone
at the bar.
Oh, my God.
It's now or never, dude.
Come on.
[ Conga music plays ]
[ Indistinct talking ]
♪♪
It's a bare...
with a hint of lavender.
Mm.
[ Clears throat ]
♪♪
Hello.
Both: Hi.
Um, Mr. Cumming,
um...
we just want to say
how big of fans we are.
-Um...
-Yes. [ Chuckles ]
Thank you so much
for bringing us here today.
For bringing you?
We followed you
for, like, 13 blocks.
Cool.
It's really cool.
It is cool.
I think
it's kind of cool.
So you're a couple?
No. [ Chuckles ]
We're just
best friends forever.
Oh, it's just...
the hat.
No, we actually just brought
Ilana's 16th cousin,
uh, 'cause he's
a Holocaust survivor.
Oh, really?
That's incredible.
My cousin.
We really need
to cherish our elders
and hear their stories.
You want
to meet him?
-Sure.
-Yeah, he's here.
You've got to meet
my 16th cousin, Alan Cumming.
-He's great.
-He's right over there.
Where is he?
-Abbi, look!
-[ Gasps ] No!
Both: Saul!
No!
[ Congo music continues ]
Ilana: Saul!
Abbi: Saul!
Both: Saul! Saul!
Oh, my God.
He's gone
for [bleep] ever!
Okay, okay.
Dude, we'll just see
where the bus stops next.
Okay.
Um...
Uh -- uh --
I can't read
a [bleep] bus map.
No, me either.
Okay.
We cannot be losing
Holocaust survivors!
Not now that the world
is gaining Nazis somehow!
Okay, okay, okay,
okay, okay.
Where would
a Holocaust survivor go?
Um...
Okay, okay.
Think, think, think.
Um, pickled herring.
Um...
Both: [ Gasps ]
Zabar's!
Yes!
Shit!
My hat, dude!
Leave the hat!
No!
It's not that simple!
[ Jewish folk music plays ]
♪♪
To the mayo-based salads.
Saul?
Saul Borowitz?
Oh, excuse me,
excuse me.
Have you seen
an elderly gentleman,
like yay high?
He's also very high
as in stoned.
Oh, he's also wearing
brightly colored
LeBron high tops.
Yes.
I don't think so.
Sorry.
Shit.
Okay.
Maybe we check down here --
Wait, Ilana.
Okay.
Um, I'm never up here,
and -- and the babka
is insane.
We got to get some
while we're here.
I will get
some whitefish salad.
Hey, can I get a pound
of whitefish salad please?
And we'll take that to go.
We're kind of in a hurry.
Thank you.
Okay, dude.
Where else would
a Holocaust survivor go?
[ Sighs ]